so we received a message from April Moss
she is a CBS Detroit whistleblower a
meteorologist whose story became public
in June of 2021 she says that she's
obtained an exclusive copy of a
resignation letter from Dan Strack of
project Veritas and that she stands by
James O'Keefe currently working on the
story and uh there is some personal
information so I'm not going to show the
email but I do have it it says today I
sent the following email to the board of
directors and Leadership project Veritas
board of directors please take this
email as notification of my resignation
as executive director of project Veritas
and project project vertas action I am
honored to have worked alongside some of
the most dedicated and driven people
I've ever met I promise I gave it my all
I want you to know how much in the past
15 months have meant to me to work with
and for you all has been incredible the
past four months have been the biggest
challenge I suspect most of us have ever
faced at least in our professional
careers it is important to me that you
know I tried my best I know you did as
well I am I'm sorry if I let you down
why now it's complicated the truth is
that I no longer know how to help I will
never forget any of you you are amazing
the world needs you take care of each
other if I can if I can ever be helpful
to you at all please reach out I hope
our paths cross again and that's uh
Dan's Strack so uh you know him
obviously yes he he worked for Goldman
Sachs and he was the executive director
that I hired uh in 2022.
2022 so he's so uh I don't know do
anything about it he's resigning I mean
this is related that's that's news to me
and uh uh
would you tell me what you think I mean
I I don't know if this uh uh so we're
receiving it from another reporter and
whistleblower well April was was a
whistleblower for CBS News she was with
supporter like two years ago she was a
meteorologist and she went live on the
air and said she's going to expose her
own network so so she's gone on to do
other reporting we've not received
confirmation from Project Veritas that
he has resigned so other than that I
don't know if you can say it's confirmed
or whether or not we know for sure that
he's actually resigned but it seems
plausible at the very least I try to be
a bit more careful on these things right
I'd rather have a statement from Project
Veritas confirming yes he did resign
right it was so I'd have to see what
April is there is there a picture or
something or uh there's there's a
screenshot of the resignation email
looks like from someone's very dirty
laptop yeah and then she just says she
has obtained an exclusive copy of
resignation letter uh from dance that's
true then Dan's resigned
I mean the the number two guy at PV is
is out I don't know when but um I don't
know when he's interesting timing it's
it's interesting timing I think it may
be related to the lawsuit I mean the
role of a the role of a board and a
non-profit is to hire and fire the CEO
which is what a board should do what a
board should not do is run the company
you can't you can't leave by committee
it doesn't work
um so that's very interesting timing and
there's obviously more to the story
there I think his resignation is is
probably related to the lawsuit and I
have to imagine it it look if you work
for Veritas especially as Veritas is
suing James O'Keefe I mean your career
is going to get nuked where are you
gonna go everyone in the media has lied
about you and called you propaganda fake
news and everything so you're not going
to CNN
now Veritas is attacking it's it's
founder who is beloved by the community
so you're basically saying if you keep
working there well they need there needs
to be there needs to be a leader like
people people there needs to be a person
like from my understanding of companies
is that again if there's a board they
hire and fire the guy at the top so the
question is who's in charge you can't
you know a board doesn't run a board
doesn't run a company a board appoints
the person that runs the company there's
nobody running it now but there has to
be there has to be so so you know are we
are we are we taking issue with the
reality that there needs to be someone
at the top is that the issue because
whoever whoever it is they're going to
be faced with the same dilemma that I
had I I was you know
I have to raise a lot of money let me go
back to this like I have to pay lawyers
to defend myself with this deal I'm not
I'm not a wealthy man
um for what I was Raising 20 25 million
a year that's a hundred thousand a day a
hundred that's if you're working a
14-hour day you know that that's that's
thousands of thousands of dollars an
hour so if I if I have to get from point
A to point B yeah I'm gonna get an SUV
because I'm on the phone with sources
well with my other phone on the on the
phone with a donor while with my toe on
the phone with an employee while typing
on my laptop because that's what I do
and and you know you need someone who's
gonna walk through walls and and by the
way what is true
and this is a mistake I will admit a
fault of mine on Monday morning I don't
ask how your weekend was
I don't say how was your Thanksgiving
I probably I probably did that twice
should a good leader ask you about that
probably
but I'm so busy trying to raise money
for all these freaking lawyers
to defend myself from all these lawsuits
because everyone wants me to fight back
and stand and stand on principle and
stand on truth
and not bend over and take it and settle
so there's a price there's a price to
pay
to not bending over do you do you think
it was a mistake starting Veritas as a
non-profit I don't regret anything in my
life because everything that I have been
through has taught me so much in many
ways this is not a a new story there's
nothing new Under the Sun but in many
ways this is a new story
we're like no one's ever gotten this far
in the video game
I mean I'm happy that I went through
what I went through
um because I had at the time you know I
had to go through that it was like
I was in a garage
in a 300 square foot like halfway house
looking piece of garage with
negative equity and I'm like well I
gotta make the video but in order to
make the video I gotta buy a microphone
in order to buy the microphone I gotta
go get money in order to get money I
gotta raise money okay I put the video
out okay now I'm being threatened with
lawsuits I gotta raise my mind to pay
lawyers so what vehicle do I need to get
to get the money to raise okay I get
into five one c three okay to get a five
one three three I need a board let me
get the board it was like you know it
was a means to an end yeah and you know
the way the way I see it now is
it's remarkable to see that over the
span of what 13 years you uh 12 and a
half 13 years you build up to to the
point of 25 million dollars a year 7
million on lawyers seven mil on lawyers
on average every year or whatever last
year five it was it was in the last few
years four and a half five seven seven
million we file public tax returns this
is all public information at 990 tax
return 7 million I had lawyers making
over a million a year
which is double my salary you can look
that up apparently some lawyers are
still making some money off of projects
and I and I got to raise money to to
defend myself here with the processes
the punishment how are you gonna how are
you going to raise half a million bucks
people say how do you do that if you go
to my telegram page you can there's a
link there's a C4 that we have I'm not
in the board I'll tweet it you can
donate but Tim I could write 30 War
Stories I was in court last September in
DC federal court Civil Trial they sued
me for breach of fiduciary duty trespass
and some other things jury trials
democracy Partners Bob creamer was that
was the video inside miles I was in a
sensory deprivation chamber AKA a
federal courtroom for like a week and a
half in Washington DC which is its own
hell hole because when you're in DC for
24 hours it's like a spiritual attack
against you yeah and there's there's a
jury and there's all these lawyers and
I'm and I'm on the witness stand
and I'm and I and I could have probably
settled the lawsuit I don't know for uh
you know something a couple hundred
grand maybe 100 Grand but I chose to do
that what I thought was the right thing
and not settle it and go to the Supreme
Court if I had to Millions yeah over a
million dollars spent it was the right
thing to do
but to do that you have to you have to
walk through walls you have to you have
to do things that people don't want to
do like my Michael Jordan said you know
leadership as a price yeah and victory
has a price
and and you know are we willing to pay
it
you want you know why um
news like what you do is so fleeting I
mean I think you do but for the audience
the rhetorical you
I've told the story before because I've
encountered this literally talking to
heads of media
you get a guy who comes into uh uh you
get a journalist or a media guy and he
goes to the investors and says I wanna
to do this investigative reporting and
expose corporate and governmental
malfeasance I need investment Capital to
get started and the Venture capitalists
and the business guys go awesome
fantastic that sounds really really good
so uh what's our return you say well you
know this kind of news does really
really well millions of views 10 million
views 20 million views it's amazing and
we can sign up people to be members
support our work so you know we could be
looking at a very lucrative Enterprise
and say yeah yeah but time timeline wise
when are you gonna get the story what's
When's the first big scoop right and you
say well I don't know we have to do the
investigation and they say how much does
that cost that's going to cost 300 000
for the preliminary investigation and
they say and how much do I get back from
that well we don't know we're
investigating a story we have no
guarantee the story pans out the way we
think it's going to that's right and
they say I am not going to invest
millions of dollars or even 300 000
unless you tell me when I get my money
back then someone else walks in the room
and says don't listen to that guy I'm
gonna launch a news company and I'm
gonna get you a two million dollar
return in three years and they go oh wow
how you gonna do it we're going to
publish click bait garbage nonsense and
complain about people's politics because
you you worked for vice right that's
right Shane Smith yep it's funny Shane
Smith might executive assistant's name
is Shane Smith with the Y not an any and
vice's uh unique value proposition was
we go there I think I saw billboard in
New York Times we or Times Square we go
there yeah something like that so their
unique value proposition was they
actually go on the location they're
reporting on and then around
2014-15 is when things started to shift
and they said you know and then they
started relying presumably this is my
opinion more on ridiculous clickbaits so
this is a really important Point
investigative reporting is like
outrageously expensive like beyond what
people can fathom because even sending
people like flights hotels you know you
know it didn't cost a lot more nowadays
lawsuits I mean we're talking you're
right hundreds of thousands dollars do
one story so if you're a businessman if
you're if you're a venture capitalist
and you want to make a profit on this
good luck
good luck to you you know what our
budget was for uh a three-day shoot we
got a story boom breaking there's a
there's there's civil unrest happening
in this country the president Megan
ousted we're sending a crew down 50
Grand
it's a bigger story it's going to take a
week or two weekends 100 200 Grand and
that was cheap
you've got salaries camera equipment
travel you need you got to have
insurance on a 30 000 camera not to
mention lawsuits legal you got people
who are going to be detained entering
the country you got people who are going
to be pulled out by cops because they're
covering the stuff you've got four
people have to go there you've got
security requirements you've got
security briefings you've got Health if
you're going to Egypt you've got to go
in for all these different vaccines you
you if you're a businessman and your
purpose is in the 90s I wrote a book
about this called American muckraker in
the 50s 60s and 70s there was Integrity
there were bosses with what I call balls
maybe you prefer huevos or testicular
fortitude whatever huevos eggs balls
bosses with balls okay I'm just gonna
say balls people in the comments be like
well I don't have balls I'm a woman okay
whatever what's a woman
2023 whatever people had balls they
would say you know what I'm you know the
cigar and the Fedora I'm gonna spend
that money because it's the right thing
to do it's the right thing to do doing
the right thing is expensive it comes at
a cost but it comes at a human cost but
it was also to a certain degree vanity
to a certain degree because you had
people running these institutions saying
we're going to be the best news
organization that's ever been and that
means going there that means going there
and we can we can but my philosophy was
always since day one day one my core
value my tenant was whatever it does
cost I will get that money to do that
thing
so that was my that was my my rason
Detra was I'm gonna go do this project
or I'm gonna have I'm gonna go get the
story if it cost me 1.4 million to get
it I'll find a way to get the money so
that I can do the thing now it's let's
get the money forget the thing let's
focus on the pursuit of that thing over
there journalism is anathema to the
commercial imperatives yes and you know
what I think happens with let's just say
insert hypothetical media nonprofit
after a certain amount of years people
get involved and they start saying hey
we're making 25 million dollars a year
that story is a little bit risky I kind
of like the way things are going that's
big money now I never thought of it that
way because I work my
I I work so hard I mean I I worked so
hard to to raise that and I never
celebrated I never celebrate getting a
check I only celebrate getting the story
and if someone on my team says oh wait
look you gotta you gotta check for 100
grand I said no we celebrate when we get
the stuff when we publish the story
that's when we celebrate
but yeah I mean I guess you could think
about it and you look at the numbers and
go wow that's some big money well I can
I can do that I can I can do that hell
with that guy he doesn't know anything
he doesn't work in private Equity he
does not manage me he's not he didn't
get a Harvard MBA I'm gonna go in there
and do that I bet it's it it's it's it
was very painful
um but it was necessary for me to get to
the next evolution of what I'm about to
do I would be willing to bet
that the near absolute majority of
people who have given to project Veritas
if they heard a story about James
O'Keefe boarding a private jet to fly
down for a vacation in Miami Beach with
a nice suit and sunglasses they'd be
laughing and clapping being like this is
exactly what the man deserves it this is
Success this is Victory if someone like
James O'Keefe can live in style with the
work that he does we're on the right
track so the idea that you simply
driving in a car was somehow offensive
or detrimental to the organization is is
laughable to me what I was saying before
is
look if you launched a private company
and from the get-go and you brought in
members and you rented as a membership
you know uh like like you're doing now
with OMG
you you'd post a picture of yourself top
G getting on a private jet with a
Bugatti or whatever and people would be
going like yes like not only are we
winning but James is flaunting his
success to show all of the corruption
and to inspire young people that there's
a path of success well Elon Musk Elon
Musk says the private transportation is
the one thing that can maximize your
time because you can have two meetings
in or three meetings in a day like there
was one oh absolutely woke up in New
York at a meeting I went to Wisconsin at
a meeting and at Arizona I had three
meetings in one day and you're you're
running a company you have to you know
you're you're raising spending a hundred
thousand a day your time this is basic
economics it's so valuable that it it
becomes imperative for you to get from
this point to this point obviously
everyone knows that but Tim we did a
story on OMG speaking of a new company
we did a story on um at the FEC we
knocked on doors and you know we just
knocked on doors it it it's it was
expensive we had to go to we gotta go
here we gotta go there but now citizens
are knocking on doors they're inspired
they're running around the country what
can I do it's it's a fraction of the
budget of these media corporations and
we're still getting results so this is
what people need to realize
the path to luxury wealth Comfort High
Society has typically been for a long
time garbage it has been people going on
TV with big fake butts in and that's
fine if you like it I got no beef
but
I've always asked myself how come
firefighters don't get paid more money
oh it's like we can't put it in the
budget we can't but police salaries are
super low the the the these leftists
want to abolish the police they complain
about cops like well cops don't get paid
very well it's not a job people want to
do and feel good and safe doing it's
high risk yet
a sports play athletes celebrities get
paid ridiculous amounts of money and the
person who is in a movie posts a video
of themselves boarding a private jet
with a you know fancy Dom Perignon or
something and everyone says if I want to
succeed and have wealth and luxury you
have to be a vapid pop culture sales
there's a lot more here that I could say
that I'm not going to because I really
sorry there's a lot more here
I don't want to get into the um there's
some things I could tell you that would
like make you go what but I don't
I don't want to be goaded into going
there because I think that's what the
the intent is here to try to get me to
do but there's there was something about
like you know people should be making
the same money or there shouldn't be a
disparity of of you know you know the
CEO shouldn't be you know having a
different form of security versus this
old guy here well well this guy's
getting attacked and his life's
threatened so you do we want to get paid
equally so some of this doesn't make a
lot a lot of actual sense
um and um
institutional capture I mean the
southern district of New York the
southern district of New York is where
the FBI rated me so now I'm being sued
in the sdny
a jury trial
in order to issue an injunction against
me to stop
exposing corruption
um by the organization that I founded
which is which mission is State
admission is to expose corruption
and they've issued a injunction to stop
the founder from exposing corruption
they have issued an injunction or or
sorry they issued they filed a lawsuit
to to request the federal courts to to
stop
um investigative reporting like I always
say like he brought this stuff to
Netflix they would like laugh at you
like this is crazy
um but just another day in my life just
to wrap up my last point we should be
happy to see the James
relaxing on a private jet we should be
like you do good work you stand up for
something honorable you help this
country you get rewarded for doing it
instead and I don't I just mean I don't
mean to just put this on you it's
something everybody everybody is in
their mind that if you're going to do
non-profit work you should be poor and
I'm not literally every single person
but I used to do non-profit fundraising
and I have to explain to people they're
like did you hear the CEO that
non-profit gets paid a million dollars
and I was like good wow which which
non-profit I didn't know you did that oh
I worked I did fundraising for a whole
bunch uh I did I did fundraising for
Greenpeace I worked for the perk groups
I worked oh that's right a handful of
others some of those are five one C4s
yeah seven cameras there he actually saw
you working
is actually a good place to probably
have some I think you're right Tim I
think I think there's nothing wrong with
taking a helicopter I mean taking a
helicopter home I I know I know people
who do that I won't name them but that's
that's a standard industry practice if
you're a 20 30 40 50 million dollar
company you get home so you can get a
good night's sleep so you can wake up
fresh and go to work and go to meetings
and go travel but there it's just part
of it's just part of business I think
the issue is that people look at things
like hopping on a private jet or a
private car as luxury instead of
necessity well what is the root of all
socialism what is the socialism Envy
yeah Envy what is socialism really about
it's about Envy oh it's not it's about
hating the guy who's achieving something
and successful tearing him down when in
reality what we should be doing is
lifting everybody up but my point is
this it's it's misplaced too so I get a
request like hey Tim we want you to fly
out here and come on this show and I'm
like okay I only fly first class that's
not because I'm like I deserve exactly
it's because okay I'm gonna be working
16 hours today I can catch a red eye
after work but I gotta go to bed I'll
sleep on the plane which barely works
and I wake up feeling like crap but I'm
willing to do that sounds like it sounds
like Envy to me yeah that's an Envy
thing thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time